-[ Jimmy humming ]
♪♪♪♪
Let me talk to you a second.
I just want to tell you
something between us.
What I have here in my box
is a stuffed animal.
[ Laughter ]
It's got a Freddy Krueger
claw on it.
Hat.
It's a wrinkly dog.
It's a wrinkly dog...
with a Freddy Krueger outfit on.
[ Laughter ]
-Sounds like my
ex-boyfriend's grandmother
♪♪♪♪
Now Cardi and I
are about to face off
in a game of "Box of Lies.
Now, here's how it works.
Upstage are a bunch of boxes
containing objects
neither of us have seen before
You remove the object
from the box,
you show it
to our great audience,
then you look at your opponent
and tell them
what's in your box.
They have to guess if you're
lying or telling the truth
[ Dramatically ] Cardi, wh
don't you pick the first box
[ Laughter ]
-[ Dramatically ]
Are you ready to play a game
Are you ready?
-[ Normal voice ]
Uh, choose the first box.
Audience, want to help her out
-Four!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Four is my lucky number.
-Four!
-Really? Okay. All right.
-11 and 4.
-All right. Do you want me
to help get this?
I don't want you
to keep getting up.
But this is all
part of the game.
-Yeah, cause you're trying
to cheat and stuff here.
-I'm not cheating!
Oh, I can tell.
I can tell it's very light
I can tell it's very --
by the way you carried it over
-[ Chuckles ] Hmm.
-[ Laughs ]
-Aah! Wait!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
-Mm-hmm. Uh-huh.
[ Audience gasps ]
Okay. All right.
[ Audience laughs ]
The audience is very --
The audience is confusing me now
because they just had like
10 different reactions.
One was [Gasps].
Then it was, "Aww!"
And then it was like, "Huh?"
And then they laughed.
-Let me touch it.
[ Laughter ]
-What is that again?
[ Laughs ]
-I'm touching it.
-Okay, you're touching it
right now.
-It's fluffy.
-Mm-hmm.
-Or is it?
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. That's not --
"It's fluffy, or is it?"
Uh-huh.
What is in your box?
-Not a penis.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
Hey! Hey!
He really wants to quit.
-No!
-What a sore loser.
-Oh, I am so --
I am ready to win.
All right, so, what is it?
What is it?
Tell me what it is.
-I don't know what it is.
-All right.
You're gonna have to
make up something because
I have to guess if you're lyin
or telling the truth.
[ Laughter ]
I don't know what it is.
-I can wait.
You can think of a name for it
And I can tell you if I think --
You have to know what it is.
-Uh, pussy balls.
[ Laughter ]
Are they pussy balls or not?
Now, pussy balls...
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
I am going to say -- I'm sayin
you tell the truth.
Let me see.
[ Laughter ]
Hey!
♪♪♪♪
I'll take --
-Can you please
hold my pussy balls?
-Nah, I knew
that was gonna happen.
Okay, good, all right.
I have your --
Here we go.
What number, guys?
-Three!
-All right. Thank you.
One person.
One person is on my side.
Unbelievable.
My sister yelled out, "Three."
Yeah. Perfect.
Here we go. Let me get this.
[ Grunting loudly ]
Ungghhh! So heavy!
I'm playing jump rope
in your head right now.
Oh, yeah.
Yep, yep, yep, yep,
yep, yep, yep!
[ Humming ]
♪♪♪♪
Let me talk to you a second.
I just want to tell you
something between us.
What I have here in my box
is a stuffed animal.
[ Laughter ]
It's got a Freddy Krueger
claw on it.
Hat.
It's a wrinkly dog.
It's a wrinkly dog...
with a Freddy Krueger outfit on.
-Sounds like my
ex-boyfriend's grandmother
[ Laughter ]
-Might be. It might be.
-You wouldn't lie to --
You wouldn't lie to a
pregnant woman, would you?
-I tell the truth! [ Chirps
-Aaah!
-I don't want to scare you
I don't want to scare you.
I don't want to scare Baby
I'm sorry, Baby!
I love you! I'm sorry!
Uncle Jimmy is sorry.
Uncle Jimmy loves you.
Can the baby
call me Uncle Jimmy?
-If I give birth here,
I will sue you.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm gonna give you --
You won. You won.
Cardi B, everybody.
We are hanging out
with John Cena, everybody!
-Yes, we are!
-[ Cheers and applause ]
-John and I are about to fac
off in a game of "Box of Lies.
Now, here's how it works.
Upstage are nine mystery boxes
containing objects
no one has ever seen before.
On your turn, you pick a box
take out the object,
and describe it
to your opponent.
They have to guess
whether you're lying
or telling the truth.
We're going to play
three rounds.
John, why don't you pick
the first box?
[ Audience shouting ]
-Far too far for me to reach
I'm going to go for four.
Gonna go for four.
-I didn't hear one person
out there say four.
[ Laughter ]
Okay, doesn't seem that heavy,
but, then again,
you're John Cena.
-That's correct.
-Nothing is heavy to John Cena
Okay.
♪♪♪♪
This is all part --
It's all part of the game
right now already.
He's deciding whether to tel
the truth or tell me a lie
Okay.
-This object, Jimmy Fallon..
-Uh-huh.
-...is made of precious metal.
-Okay.
Precious metal.
-And gemstones.
Precious metal and gemstones
-It's beautiful to look at
-Okay.
-And if you were
to see it up close,
you wouldn't be able
to look away.
[ Light laughter ]
-It's something bejeweled.
-It might be.
[ Light laughter ]
Actually, it certainly is,
because I just --
because I just told you it was
-That's right.
Yeah, you did, yeah.
-And I am holding,
from box number four,
cosmetic lipstick.
-Lipstick.
-Yeah.
-So what you're saying
is it's a bejeweled lipstick
-Yes.
-Why didn't you just say tha
in the first place?
That's ridiculous.
I mean, this is the --
this is the dumbest thing
that anyone's ever done
in the history of the game
"Box of Lies."
If that's really
a lipstick container,
that took 20 minutes for you t
describe a lipstick container.
-This is your game, bro.
-Precious metal --
-I was just trying --
-Precious metals and gems?
-Yes, yes!
-It's a lipstick container
-It is a lipstick container.
-You are telling the truth
-I am.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-But it says -- it says,
"Open and twist."
-Yeah.
-Now, that --
-You shanghaied me!
-Now, that would have --
that would have been something
to talk about.
Here we go.
Guys, what box?
What number?
[ Audience shouting ]
Three.
Give them what they want.
-Three.
Go for it.
-[ Groaning ]
-So, it's not heavy.
[ Laughter ]
-Whoop.
-I've seen you strain.
-[ Singing ]
-It's not -- It's not large.
It's not large.
You're trying to -- You're
trying to think up an untruth.
-It's not large.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪♪♪
It's...
It's two little honeybees.
And they're -- they're, uh..
[ Laughter ]
They're playing --
What's that jump-rope game
that you jump --
-Double Dutch.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-They're playing two double --
Two double bubbles.
-So you couldn't identify th
insects or the jump-rope game.
-The jump-rope game
double Dutch.
And, yeah.
And there's two fuzzy bumblebees
playing it.
And their friends that are
playing along with them are --
-You --
-Two --
-You are not good.
-They are two, um...
praying mantises.
-Oh, fantastic.
Fantastic, yes.
All right.
-Manti.
Praying manti.
-Okay, that -- You know what
-The plural of "mantis."
-That swung me.
-There's no way
you're telling the truth.
You're lying.
♪♪♪♪
-Welcome to my --
[ Foghorn blows ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
What number do you want
from John Cena?
[ Audience shouting ]
-I have a one.
I have a whole section.
Sorry, six guy.
I have a whole section
saying, "One."
All right.
-"Six guy."
-One.
Forever be known as six guy.
Okay.
-Sorry, six guy.
-All right.
-Whew.
All right.
[ Clears throat ]
[ Light laughter ]
Okay.
♪♪♪♪
-It's art.
-Okay.
It's art.
-I find it beautiful.
-Okay.
-I think it
combines industrialism
with the early stages
of television.
[ Light laughter ]
-Industrialism, okay.
-I hold in my hands
a red and black
double pinstripe model
of a 1970 Chevy Chevelle SS.
And in the driver's seat
is the Fonz.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
From the looks of it,
it looks like a four-speed car
It does look like it has
a 12-bolt rear end.
It appears to be a big block
It is a Super Sport model.
-I know you --
-The Fonz is wearing his classic
black leather jacket.
-Uh-huh, uh-huh.
-He's a smaller figurine
in the passenger seat,
but it also looks like
he's wearing blue jeans,
if he has any pants on at all.
[ Light laughter ]
-So you're telling me -- you'r
telling me that there's a --
there's a pantless Fonz
driving...
a 1970, like -- some type
of a souped-up muscle car.
-No, it's not --
Here's the thing.
It's not souped-up.
It is absolutely factory stock
-Oh, keep talking, buddy.
Keep talking, 'cause guess what.
I know you, buddy.
I know you, Johnathan Cena
Johnathan Cena, I know you
And I know that you like cars.
So, I think
that you made this up.
This is a lie.
Is that right?
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Bell dinging ]
I love you, man.
I know you, dude.
I know you love cars.
[ Cheers and applause ]
John Cena, everybody!
Oh, my goodness.